Even though the festival invited me, I was just distracted by my name.
That's why I'm angry.
[Music]
I have to make up for something. I
'm sorry.
I
'm sorry I'm
sorry, why am I so samurai-sama? I'm
jealous of the lack of life
.  Bold and
sick
, don't jet when it's cold
Sisters are so normal
[Music]
Too happy
You're
still warm Hey
, it was still hot and uncomfortable when I started sleeping in the same bed  But it's very useful in winter
Oh,
I'm
asking for someone's response like this
I don't know if it's because I'm distorted
[Music]
I don't know what everyone is doing, but
if four lives come out, I'm pretty distorted too  -I
always give up because I want to touch something unknown c
The bus is already the second one, so I
'm seriously wearing grass shoes,
let's walk